so my name is Rebecca Amundsen and I'm
the deputy mayor of the endocardial City
Council I'm here today with my dog Leroy
he's a springer spaniel nearly three
years old
and we just want to talk a wee bit about
orici Beach so we really want to
encourage people to come to the beach
over the summer and make the most of
this amazing asset that we have and by
having fun here with their family their
friends their pets and their toys but
we've got a few messages that we just
want to let you know about so that you
have a safe and enjoyable time at the
beach looking after not only your family
and friends but also looking after the
environment so the first thing is about
looking after yourself please make sure
you swim between the flags if you're
using a vehicle on the beach please make
sure that you're being safe with how you
use a vehicle treat it like a road and
make sure you wear a helmet if you're on
motorbikes and with the environment we
really want you to take your rubbish
home with you please don't leave that
lying around you know that's dangerous
kids might stand on glass things like
that and it's also bad for the marine
life and we also want to take good care
of the Toa role which are living under
the sand right where you will be sitting
and driving on the beach so please enjoy
the asset that we have at ret Beach but
please take care and enjoy the summer